it's the sound that fans of 80s rally
cars love and reminds many of a very
special car the audi quattro s1 now audi
is resurrecting the legendary s1 as the
new top city model of the audi a1 the
two cars may be different but the
similarities are clear both are powered
by the quattro all-wheel drive
then I'm as I her car tester close needs
fit says the name s1 stems from a sporty
car that featured in world rallies in
the 1980s driven by famously fast
drivers like Volta rural and Stig
Blomqvist unlike the original the new s1
can be bought by anyone
and impose quite a few sporty features
huge breaks Cointreau logo
rear spoiler and four exhaust pipes and
the s-1 proves its skills on the road
powerful breaking sharp steering and the
wheels have a phenomenal grip on the
asphalt thanks to all wheel technology
and the 2-liter turbocharged engine is
impressive when accelerating out of
curds no other car in the segment packs
such as sporty punch
as he closes the new Audi s1 shows its
real strengths on the test track it's
got a great electro mechanical power
steering system and the all-wheel drive
means you can really step on the gas
exiting a bend so in short claw says the
newest one is a great sportsman dekhana
established he got goals a choise line
and great sportsman need big hearts
a two liter engine shoots this little
machine forward in no time but it takes
more than pure power not to fly off the
track in snow and ice driving and icy
conditions can be tricky but seasoned
drivers can work the s-1 easily and
literally make it dance around on the
snow the s-1 is perfect because much of
its weight sixty percent is concentrated
in the front you almost feel like
Quattro maestro Stig Blomqvist
what does the famous driver make of a
new s1 compared with its predecessor
al-qaeda no one is really nice and ok 30
years between them so it's not really
something you can compare and the same
goes for the sleek interior high quality
materials and an eye for detail
underscore the cars sporty elegance a
gearshift knob and aluminum sports
steering
and bucket seats
the new s1 accelerates in just under six
seconds to 100 kilometers and rocks on
to a top speed of 250 it's 170 kilowatt
engine has a fuel consumption of 7.1
liters and Germany car lovers will need
to shell out over 30 thousand euros for
the new 5-door s1 sports back
so what's the verdict of our car tester
Klaus says he's surprised the car looks
good is great to handle a sturdy and
crazily fast so it has everything you'd
expect from a small sports bag he says
Oh to test it today our car Chester
Sasha can app will examine the new honda
civic with a 1.6 litre diesel engine up
till now honda hasn't played much of a
role in germany and 2013 at so less than
23,000 vehicles figures for Europe as a
whole look a little better almost
150,000 cars sold but globally honda is
a major player selling 4.3 million autos
a year now honda is presenting the Civic
tourer tailored to the german market in
a bid to boost sales here but can t
compete with a VW covariant an assault
king budget sized info vegan taught
that's one month or two and so on the
Civic turers design is much more dynamic
than most hatchbacks nothing stolid or
square here the tour distinguishes
itself well from the crowd both in front
and in the rear we especially like the
broad wheel wells but the tirs design
reduces the driver's ability to see all
around
asanda sasha says I'm too serious
interest in the German market is shown
by the trunk one of the largest in this
class it holds 624 litres and when you
put the seat down 1668 liters it has an
additional compartment under a hatch on
the trunk floor Sasha also likes the low
trunks ill just 55 centimeters which
makes it easier to load neatly a lot it
come to Tibbett Lake Nevada my thumb 150
centimeter on the road the turfs dynamic
appearance is matched by its dynamic
handling the steering is precise and the
engine is spirited that's partly due to
its 300 newton meters of torque but also
to its lightweight the 1.6 litre diesel
engine weighs 50 kilograms less than the
2-liter engine it replaces Sasha likes
the crisp precise transmission
you
hina bazan died he says what's special
about the honda civic tour is its
adaptive undercarriage most adaptive
axle systems involved all the wheels the
Civic tourer regulates only the rear
axle because Honda assumes that the
weight on the front axle will remain the
same but since up to 500 kilograms can
be loaded at the rear its burden here
can vary widely so the jurors axles can
be adjusted between three settings
normal dynamic or comfort as required
namas this to come for take long the
Civic Torres interior has a sporty
modern feel the overall appearance is
convincing but the large number of
buttons on the center console is a bit
confusing I'm the Dutchman I'm Sasha
points out a rare feature have you ever
tried to transport a bicycle in your car
in the honda civic tour you don't have
to rearrange the trunk you just hold the
back seat upward and there's room for a
bicycle the civic tour has many details
that German customers will like no
wonder it was developed for the European
market and this Japanese car is actually
British it rolls off the assembly line
in Swindon in southwestern England Sasha
isn't happy that the engine can be heard
during the entire drive but it's not so
loud that it's really bothersome an eco
button on the dashboard lets you see how
ecologically you're driving according to
the position of the gas pedal and allows
you to regulate it accordingly being
green is the declared goal of the 1.6
litre diesel engine in the earth dreams
technology series honda says the Civic
tours normal diesel consumption is 3.8
liters per 100 kilometer
only 99 grams of co2 emissions per 100
kilometers is pretty good too the diesel
hatchback costs twenty one thousand five
hundred fifty euros invest a little more
and Honda throws in a few assistant
systems including automatic distance
control and an emergency brake assist
Sasha sums up the honda civic tour
clearly demonstrates that it's a viable
alternative to the VW golf that's more
storage space than any other vehicle in
this segment it's price is comparable to
that of the gulf so you have to be
prepared to spend quite a bit but you do
get value for your money
peace by pick up your car test amatis
karad points out that just as there are
small compact cars for the city and big
ones for long distance travel trucks
have different models too so what are
they exactly that's a question for
sukkah forum on Logan number Sadie's
pants she says that depends on the kind
of trip drivers who do long haul are
usually on the road for several days so
they need a comfortable sleeper cab in
the truck with the bed and enough room
where they can stay the night while City
trips on the other hand involves drivers
starting in the morning distributing
their goods and going home at night so
those drivers don't need all those
facilities and that means trucks plying
in the city have smaller more compact
driver cabinets which is better since
they often have to maneuver in smaller
spaces for Tyler for care and it was
evil 60 here fri so to have a stock of
myungsoo cane canncel gong xi own good
so marthis is now going to test this
mercedes at t go to see how it performs
its mouth so we head out onto a country
road at a height of around 2 meters
above ground Montes can now try out this
big machine and it's not just his high
vantage point that allows him to get a
good overview
what monta says despite its huge size
compared to a car it isn't really
difficult to get a grip on the ax t go
thanks to the six mirrors mounted around
the driver's cabin but what he'd really
like is a camera so that he can see
what's exactly happening behind the
vehicle but during the trip there's
mostly just a line of cars to be seen in
Germany most trunks are limited to 80
km/h
while driving the ax t go with a
permissible total weight of 7.5 tons
it's a weight category popular around
the world and not just with haulage
firm's motto says that people who got
their card driver's license in Germany
before 1998 are also allowed to drive
seven and a half ton trucks like the
Antigua here that means many people who
usually don't drive a truck can also use
this vehicle for instance when they're
moving he says the automatic gearbox
makes it easier to get used to the truck
because all you have to do is keep your
eyes on the road steer brake and
accelerate of the transit cocomo's
lengthen on cleansing and cascade but
you have to be careful with side wins
because of the large truck as long as
you don't load the truck to its full
capacity you don't have to worry about
stability because the main weight of a
truck is centered around its axles
nimby mata says in addition to the ax t
go there are heavier truck models that
can have a total weight of up to 40 tons
I please does Nikki ines actos but here
to there are special vehicles for long
haul and short haul trips sycophant
Logan says the mercedes actros model has
sleeper cabs for long haul trips that
are two meters 40 wide and have a
uniform floor but that's not needed for
the city when a drivers on the road for
several days he needs to have a feel of
a home for day trips a driver does not
need a sleeper cam with big dimensions
and lots of comfort and this is where
you have tailor-made options she says
Romeo apne Sofia come for beated when
here is even design capo di di often
inside swag favor for tyler phu khao sok
ish knitting and there are other
requirements for garbage trucks here
getting in and out of the vehicle has to
be made easy as well as turning into
narrow streets
this mitsubishi fuso canter shows that
trucks don't have to always be big to
transport a lot its compact structure
allows it to carry the biggest load in
its segment and there's also a diesel
hybrid version
as an expletive Baptist says the fuzhou
cancer isn't just unbelievably flexible
its hybrid engine is great because you
can save around four liters of diesel on
100 kilometers so after four years
you've got back the additional eight
thousand euros you paid on the price you
always have a 10 year guarantee on
hybrid parts it's not a bad deal but
Montes says it remains to be seen if the
hybrid engine can compete with the
conventional diesel version that's the
LTS not tagging
the Ford a speedster was one of the
earliest models and automobile racing in
the 1920s daredevil men would race
around dusty tracks and vehicles like
this one this 1929 model boasts 40
horsepower and can reach speeds of up to
100 kilometers an hour at a time when
most people were still traveling by
horse and carriage it was revolutionary
but for Klaus villain speed is not the
primary interest it's the whole driving
experience he's been a lifelong vintage
car enthusiast and has a particular
passion for ford cars from before the
Second World War I spend a long time he
says trying to trace the old racing cars
that were based on the Ford a model but
not produced in Ford factories I
discovered a factory in South America
that specialized in these cars so I went
over there and saw that their cars were
good and authentic and the decision was
made South kunis is correct on Tasha
boss pursuit Klaus Muller ordered a
speedster body from Argentina his goal
was to build an authentic Ford a
speedster parts like the dashboard
instruments and steering wheel he was
able to buy at vintage car markets it
took hundreds of hours of work but
eventually he was able to fulfill his
dream
this is all is hunky Boston everything
is them put together by handy sense the
bodywork was made without any modern
equipment it was all shaped by hand and
if you look closely you can see lots of
irregularities everything has been done
as it would have been done back then
it's been riveted rather than screwed
together but there are no holla rivets
Silvio Martinez I'll captain ma from
Conan or Die came off head to the engine
came from an old Ford a from 1929 Klaus
Muller gave it a complete overhaul
before fitting it into his car
l'italia photography finding spare parts
is no problem he says you can basically
get everything there are a few parts
that are no longer produced but you
don't need them anyway all the parts
that we're out you can buy and if
everything's adjusted correctly you can
do the maintenance yourself change the
oil check the spark plugs minor things
like that from Connie's curtain on this
katana Klaus doesn't believe in just
admiring his cars in the garage he
drives his speedster frequently the
speedster is surprisingly normal to
drive it's not so different from modern
cars the clutch is the same there's a
three-speed transmission the main
difference is that you're exposed to the
elements and because of the noise it's
not so easy to chat with your passenger
by far the Ford a speedster a pre-war
classic with a feel of a racing car and
as they're easy to build and maintain
there are still quite a number of Model
A's around today
you